[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge in Vertretung von Toni bin
ich heute mal wieder dran ich bin Stefan
Netzeband hallo und ich bin Mirco hallo
heute ergründen wir die Abgründe in die
eine verletzte Seele in ihrer Trauer
geraten kann erst recht wenn man sich
dazu in eine Sucht verliert
unser heutiger Fall ist nichts für
empfindliche Hörer versteht das ruhig
als ganz konkrete triggerwarnung hier
geht es um grausame Morde und
verstörende Momente bei der Beseitigung
von Toten wer also darauf sensibel
reagiert der sollte diese Folge lieber
auslassen bei Dennis Nielsen in
Schottland fängt schon mal alles
schlecht an
Dennis Nielsen wird 1945 als der Jünger
von zwei Söhnen des Ehepaars Betty und
Olaf Nielsen geboren die Familie wohnt
im schottischen Fräser war im Bezirk von
Everdeen sein Vater kommt aus Norwegen
ist Soldat und schwerer Alkoholiker er
verlässt die Familie als Dennis gerade
mal zwei Jahre alt ist nach der
Scheidung gründet die Mutter eine neue
Familie sie heiratet noch mal und nimmt
den Namen Scott an
Dennis wächst jetzt bei seinem Opa auf
einem Fischer als der Junge sieben Jahre
alt ist verunglückt der Großvater
tödlich auf Sie Dennis wird zum in sich
gekehrten Einzelgänger er meldet sich
schon mit 15 Jahren freiwillig zum
Militär da wird er es zum Koch dann
machte eine schlachterausbildung und er
beginnt zu saufen
nach der Militärzeit geht Nielsen in den
Polizeidienst aber nur für ein paar
Monate im November 1975 begegnet Nielsen
in London einem 20-jährigen Mann namens
David glitchen als der vor einem Pub von
zwei anderen Männern bedroht wird
Nielsen rettet geliebigen und bringt ihn
in sein Zimmer die beiden Männer
betrinken sich und freunden sich an sie
werden sogar ein paar und ziehen
zusammen dafür setzt Nielsen seinen
väterliches Erbe ein und kaufte Möbel um
eine Mietwohnung einzurichten sie liegt
im Erdgeschoss eines Hauses mit Garten
in der Melrose Avenue im Londoner
Stadtteil wohnt aber das ganze hält
nicht lange gelegen zieht schließlich
aus und zurück bleibt ein trauriger
einsamer Dennis ein Jahr darauf 1978 wie
geht Dennis Nielsen seinen ersten Mord
sowie er ist später schildert steckt
dahinter zunächst überhaupt gar keine
Absicht ironischerweise arbeitet Niel
übrigens mittlerweile als
Sozialarbeiter beim Arbeitsamt und soll
jungen Männern bei der Jobsuche helfen
in einer Kneipe begegnet er dem erst
14-jährigen ihrem Stephen Holmes die
beiden betrinken sich und freunden sich
an Dennis bietet Steven an bei ihm zu
übernachten der ist unschlüssig kommt
aber erstmal mit schließlich pennt der
Junge auf Dennis Sessel ein
am nächsten Morgen überkommen Nielsen
heftige leidenschaftliche Gefühle auf
keinen Fall will er das Steven geht er
wirkt den noch schlafenden Gast mit
einer Krawatte bewusstlos dann ertrinkt
er den Jungen mit Hilfe eines Eimers
Wasser
schließlich hat er Sex mit der Leiche er
wäscht den Körper und versteckt ihn
unter dem Dielenboden der einsame Sohn
des Trinkers der selber säuft der
unglückliche Einzelgänger der seinen
Großvater vermisst er verspürt immer
wieder Lust und hol zu seinem Vergnügen
noch mehrfach den Toten Steven aus
seinem Versteck Monate nach dem ersten
Mord verbrennt Nils sind die Leiche von
Stephen Holmes im Garten sie hatte
längst angefangen zu riechen damit die
Nachbarn nicht aufmerksam werden fackelt
er gleichzeitig Autoreifen ab
hier hat eine fürchterliche Mordserie
begonnen obwohl die Polizei ein knappes
Jahr später die Chance hat noch alles
aufzuhalten im November 1979 trifft
Nielsen in einer Kneipe den Chinesen
Andrew hole die beiden gehen zu Dennis
nach Hause sie wollen Fessel Sex
versuchen ho lässt sich ans Bett binden
schließlich fängt Dennis an seinen Gast
heftig zu wirken der Chinese kann sich
rechtzeitig befreien und flieht er rennt
zur Polizei aber jetzt passiert das
Unfassbare die Beamten konfrontieren
Dennis mit hausvorwürfen und der erzählt
dass er eigentlich das Opfer ist der
Chinese habe versucht ihn auszurauben
schwer zu sagen ob hier Rassismus im
Spiel ist aber auf jeden Fall glauben
die Beamten Nielsen am dritten dezember
1979 geht er mal wieder in ein Pub und
lernt einen ahnungslosen Mann kennen
diesmal handelt es sich um den
23-Jährigen kanadischen Studenten
der macht eine Rundreise durch England
um Verwandte zu besuchen
Nielsen trinkt mit ihm bietet sich als
Stadtführer an und lädt den jungen Mann
zu sich nach Hause ein dort erwirkt er o
Candy mit einem Kabel und lässt die
Leiche erst mal liegen am nächsten Tag
kauft er sich eine Polaroid Kamera und
fotografiert sein Opfer es beginnt
völlig Kranke schräge Tage an den Nils
in die Leiche immer wieder mal in
Dielenboden versteckt sie dann wieder
rausholt ein Plastik einwickelt sich
zwischendurch ständig betrinkt und den
toten Körper wieder wegpackt auch bei
seinem dritten Mord kommt Nielsen
offenbar so gute dass er als
Sozialarbeiter leicht Zugang zu jungen
Männern findet
als er von einer gewerkschaftstagung
zurückkehrt trifft er am Bahnhof den
16-Jährigen Ausreißer Martin Duffy der
hatte schon mehrere Nächte im Freien
verbracht und lässt sich gern zu Nils
nach Hause einladen dort wirkt Niesen
sein Opfer und er tränkt es schließlich
an der Leiche vergeht der Mörder sich
bis der Geruch nicht mehr vertragen ist
diese Geschichten Stichwort ertragen die
sind nämlich nur schwer zu ertragen es
sind in der Summe auch einfach zu viele
feststeht bis zum Ende des Jahres 1980
tötet der Schotte noch mindestens fünf
weitere Männer in der Wohnung in der
Melrose Avenue er muss auf dem
Grundstück ein großes Feuer mit vielen
Autoreifen machen um alle Spuren zu
beseitigen und teilweise gucken bei
diesen feiern Nachbarskinder zu ohne zu
ahnen was da vor sich geht die
Geschichte des letzten Opfers in dieser
Wohnung ist besonders tragisch der
23-Jährige Malcolm Balo lehnt Schmerz
verzerrt an nilses Hauswand der
Sozialarbeiter spricht ihn an Barlo
erklärt er habe wegen seiner Medikamente
gegen epileptische Krämpfe Probleme mit
den Beinen Nielsen nimmt den Mann mit
nach Hause und ruft einen Krankenwagen
als Barlo aus dem Krankenhaus
zurückkehrt besucht er dankbar seinen
Retter denn es Nielsen der serviert im
Cola rum
ihr ahnt es erwürgt auch ihn schließlich
1981 soll die Wohnanlage in der Melrose
Avenue saniert werden und Nielsen
bekommt das Angebot gegen gutes Geld
auszuziehen am 5 Oktober 81 bezieht er
deshalb eine Dachgeschosswohnung im
Bezirk massual Hill im Norden Londons
Adresse cranley Gardens 23 vorher
verbrannte auf seinem alten Grundstück
noch die letzten Reste seiner letzten
Opfer in cranley gardens gibt es weder
Bodendielen noch einen Garten hier
hätten Nielsen einen Mischlingshund
namens blieb und tatsächlich kommt es
jetzt öfter vor das Nielsen Besuch
bekommt und dieser leben das Haus
verlässt es braucht eine Weile bis der
Serienmörder sein schreckliches treiben
wieder aufnimmt wieder lockt der junge
Männer in die Wohnung macht sie
betrunken und erwürgt sie die Leichen
entsorgt er notgedrungen anders
zerkleinerte Knochen und und Gewebe in
den Hausmüll und zum Teil auch in der
Toilette zu einem besonders die
zarrenvorgang wird der Besuch eines
jungen Mannes namens Karl stotter
Nielsen Schnack den 21-Jährigen Schwulen
in einer Kneipe mit als der schließlich
betrunken in einem Schlafsack liegt
versucht Nielsen ihn zu erwürgen aber
diesmal gelingt es ihm nicht weder mit
bloßen Händen noch durch Untertauchen in
der Badewanne vielleicht ist er selber
zu betrunken oder zu nervös in diesem
Fall auf jeden Fall fängt's total immer
wieder an zu atmen schließlich gibt
Nielsen auf und erzählt seinem Opfer
zwei Tage später eine wirklich
abenteuerliche Geschichte
erster habe sich im Reißverschluss des
Schlafsackes verfangen und selbst
gewirkt Nielsen habe ihn gerettet und
Wiederbeleben müssen und schließlich in
die Badewanne gesteckt damit er wieder
zu Bewusstsein komme
Starter sicher noch schwer mal trittiert
und verkatert kauft ihm die falsche
rettungsgeschichte ab die beiden
verabschieden sich gerührt voneinander
und umarmen sich
wenn man den Fall so zusammenfasst wie
wir das jetzt hier anhand der Unterlagen
und Artikel tun da kann man denken
Nielsen hat die ganze Zeit immer wieder
gemordet entweder oder getrunken oder
beides aber erstaunlicherweise hat er ja
über all die Jahre nach außen hin
funktioniert im Jahr 1981 wird er als
städtische Angestellter im Sozialdienst
sogar befördert und unfassbar drei
Monate danach trifft er an einem
Taxistand den 27-Jährigen Graham allen
während sie warten kommen sie charmant
ins Gespräch
Ellen lässt sich nach krenley Gardens
zum Essen einladen nach dem Omelett
erwürgt Nielsen seinen Gast drei Tage
vergeht er sich an dessen Körper weil er
anschließend Zeit braucht die Leiche zu
zerkleinern und zu entsorgen meldet er
sich krank am 26 januar
1983 tötet Nielsen sein letztes Opfer
der 20-Jährige Steven Sinclair wird
sogar von bekannten noch in Begleitung
Nielsens gesehen als die beiden zur
U-Bahn gehen in Dennis Wohnung schläft
sincla völlig zugedröhnt ein Nielsen
hört die Rockoper Tommy von The Who
während er den Mann tötet dabei entdeckt
er schließlich tiefe Schnittwunden an
simcas Handgelenken er erkennt sein
Opfer hat offenbar erst kürzlich
versucht sich das Leben zu nehmen
nächstens Bemühungen die Leichen zu
entsorgen gleichen mittlerweile einer
planlosen Improvisation
er lagert Einzelteile in einer Teekiste
andere entsorgte im Hausmüll immer
wieder kocht er auch Teile und versucht
sie im Klo runter zu spüren
wir nähern uns und zum Glück muss man
sagen dem Ende dieses Grauens ich meine
in vielen Fällen werden Mörder gefasst
weil es Zeugenaussagen gibt oder
überwachungsaufnahmen oder auch
DNA-Spuren haben wir alles in dieser
podcastreihe schon gehabt aber manchmal
führen eben auch ganz plumpe
Beweismittel zum Mörder vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch zum Beispiel an den
Fall der Eis Lady mit den Leichen in der
Kühltruhe sonst hört euch diesen Fall
ruhig noch mal an weil denn es Nielsen
bringt all dieser Schweinkram mit den
Leichen die Polizei schließlich auf die
Spur am 8 februar wird der Sanitär
Notdienst
23 gerufen weil die Abflüsse verstopft
sind der Arbeiter Michael Katrin kommt
am späten Nachmittag zum Haus und öffnet
ein abwassersiel an der Seite
darin befinden sich klebriger Schleim
sowie Fleischstücke und knochengeister
sieht alles nach viel Arbeit aus denkt
Katrin und ruft seinen Chef Gary Wheeler
an er werde sich das am nächsten Tag im
Hellen alles genauer ansehen und den
Schaden beheben okay sagt sein Chef
bevor Kathrin zusammenpackt und geht
trifft also sogar noch zufällig auf
Dennis Nielsen und spricht mit ihm über
die Lage das werden wohl Speisereste von
Kentucky Fried Chicken sein sagt der am
nächsten Tag rückt Katrin mit seinem
Chef Wheeler an aber da hat schon jemand
dass sie ihr gereinigt nur in einem Rohr
das aus der oberen Wohnung kommt sieht
man noch Fleischfetzen den
Installateuren kommt spätestens jetzt
alles sehr merkwürdig vor an dieser
Geschichte sie rufen die Polizei
[Musik]
für die Beamten die sich schließlich
Zutritt zunielsens Wohnung verschaffen
muss dieser Einsatz der wahre Albtraum
sein die ganze Bude stinkt nach
Verwesung Leichenteile finden sich in
der Teekiste oder im Schrank als sie
Nielsen abführend Fragen die Polizisten
ob es sich um ein oder zwei Mordopfer
handelt Nielsen antwortet teilnahmslos
15 oder 16 seit 1978 nach seiner
Verhaftung gesteht Nielsen die Morde
noch mal offiziell es seien 15 gewesen
sagt er jetzt drei davon in seiner
derzeitigen Wohnung und 12 in seiner
vorherigen zunächst gibt sich Nielsen
ahnungslos was seine Motive angeht aber
später kommt der regelrecht ins
Schwärmen wie nah er einigen seine Opfer
gekommen sei wie weich ihre Haut war wie
intensiv seine Gefühle am 24 Oktober
1983 wird die Gerichtsverhandlung gegen
Dennis Nielsen im Central criminal Cord
von London eröffnet obwohl er 15 Morde
und fünf Mordversuche gestanden hat kann
ihm die Staatsanwaltschaft nur sechs
vollzogene Morde wirklich nachweisen
auch zwei versuchte Morde gelten durch
die Aussagen als gesichert am 4 november
wird der Perverse Sozialarbeiter der mal
ein vereinsamtes verängstigtes
Trennungskind war zu lebenslanger Haft
vorurteilt bis zu seinem Tod sitzt er
mehr als 34 Jahre davon ab Dennis
Nielsen stirbt am 10 Mai 2018 an inneren
Blutungen ursache soll der Riss eine
Hauptschlagader im Oberkörper gewesen
sein und damit sind wir am Ende unseres
heutigen falls wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und freuen uns wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid
wenn ihr Anregungen Lob Kritik oder
fallvorschläge habt über die wir hier
mal berichten sollen dann schreibt uns
gerne eine E-Mail oder eine Nachricht
war Instagram bis zum nächsten mal euer
Mirko und euer Stefan